All then we have jimminy cricket,
that's south southern US slang for Jesus
Christ by the way.
And the initial overlap isn't a fluke.
I mean,
I'm sure the animators thought that was
funny and of course it is funny and you
know,
in,
in the lion king,
you know that that at bat boone,
who is the shaman basically?
Well,
to begin with,
he was kind of just a comic relief
character,
like a fool,
you know.
But one of the things young mentioned
about the fool,
the fool tends to turn into the savior.
It's an,
it's an archetypal reality.
Bugs bunny is sort of like that,
you know,
he's a trickster.
And as the,
as the movie developed,
the character of the fool,
baboons took on the full fledged,
you know,
Shaman,
priest element and,
and you know,
okay,
well Jimminy cricket,
he's this little cricket and,
and he turns out to be the conscience,
which is pretty damn weird.
It's like a bug is your conscience and a
bug is jc and it's like that's a very
strange juxtaposition of ideas,
conscience,
insect,
savior.
It's like,
what,
what's up with that?
And so.
Well,
what bugs you,
that's part of it,
while your conscious conscience
certainly bugs you and you should pay
attention to.
It's just little niggling annoying thing
that you can't quite.
You can override it,
right?
Obviously,
but it's this swallowed.
And he says,
when he talks to Pinocchio later,
he says it's that still small voice,
you know,
and I've asked people before,
like in my personality class,
like [inaudible] conscience is a weird
thing.
And,
and like if I said to you,
if you're about to do something that you
know you shouldn't do,
do you have a voice in your head that
tells you that you shouldn't do it?
So how many people have had that
experience?
Okay,
okay,
good.
Now,
so other people have a feeling instead
of a voice.
And so is there anybody here who's
willing to admit it?
Who has neither the feeling nor the
voice?
Okay.
So,
and you know,
it's a very understudied phenomena in
psychology.
This conscience.
I mean people can be conscientious and
maybe those are people who listen to
their conscience more.
I don't know,
but nobody's ever investigated it.
And the fact that you do have this
little voice,
whatever it is inside your head,
it's like,
what the hell is up with that?
You know?
And it doesn't tell you what you want to
hear,
at least as far as I can tell.
Now you could say,
well,
that's the internal representation of
society operating within you.
That'd be a Freudian view.
That's the Super Ego.
And certainly there's something to that,
but I don't think it's necessary to
presume that that's all there is to it.
And even if it is,
you still wouldn't have the voice.
It's if you didn't have the biological
potential to have that voice embedded
itself in you.
So even if it is socio culturally
constructed,
which it is in part,
it's like language.
It's like your language associate
culturally constructed,
but the reason you can speak is because
human beings can speak and if you have a
conscience,
that's because human beings have a
conscience and the contents of that
might differ.
But the fact that it exists,
what seems to be to be universal,
okay,
so well that's the conscience and that's
Jimminy cricket.
And then click the cricket opens this
book,
and then you look at the book and you
think,
well what kind of book is that?
Well,
it's got a spotlight on it.
So it's being highlighted.
This is an important book.
And what kind of book is it?
Well,
it's leather bound.
It has a lock on it,
you know,
it's not some cheap book.
It's kind of like a,
you might think about,
it looks like something from an old
library or maybe it looks biblical,
whatever.
It's a major league book.
And this bug is the introduction to the
book.
So it does that mean your conscience is
the introduction to the book?
Well maybe that is what it means.
It's certainly what's being played out
in the movie while then the cricket
opens the book.
And so then what do you see?
Well,
what does that look like?
What does it look like?
What does it remind you of?
Okay,
so that's the van Gogh painting.
It's a nativity scene.
It's the,
it's the Christmas star and you know
that because what's going to happen?
Well,
the hero is going to be born.
That's what happens.
And so a star signifies that,
why does this star signify the birth of
an infant,
let's say?
Well,
because there's something miraculous
about the birth of an infant and,
and why would the infant be a savior,
which is the Christian notion say,
well,
because that's what the infant is
potentially every infant.
And so that's how you should act about
them.
And you know,
one of the things that really is
interesting about having little kids,
and I loved having little kids,
is that you have this opportunity to
have this pristine relationship with
someone like,
like a relationship you've never had
with anyone because the kid really is
just there to love you.
You like,
if you don't screw it up,
you've got that.
And then you can keep that going.
You know?
And you can try to keep that
relationship like pristine.
And that's so fun.
It's so fun to try to do that.
It's,
it's really,
it's amazing.
It's an amazing thing and you know,
kids get a bad rap in our society,
but it's an amazing thing to helped
little kids and they are remarkable and
they give you back far more than they
require from you and partly because they
treat you like you're,
you're valuable beyond belief.
That's what the kid thinks about you.
It's like,
that's pretty good.
So yeah,
it's something divine is going to happen
and so okay,
fine,
you know,
fair enough.
Well,
there's The star signifying that and,
and that's associated in some way with
this star that you're supposed to wish
upon.
Well,
that's kind of odd.
Like there's this,
there's this relationship that's
implicit,
that star that signifies the birth of
the hero is the same star that you wish
upon.
Well
perhaps the star that you're wishing
upon is the wish that the hero will be
born in your soul.
It's something like that.
You're aiming at the ideal,
right?
It's the ideal you,
whatever that would be.
Well,
you can certainly figure out what it
isn't.
That's where you start as far as I can
tell,
you know,
what you shouldn't be doing and you
could at least stop doing those things
and then see what happens,
you know,
and if you ask yourself,
it's a meditative exercise,
you know,
and you do this with the autobiography
to some degree.
It's like,
okay,
sit down for 10 minutes and have a
little dialogue with yourself.
Like you actually wanted to know the
answer,
you know?
So yeah,
ask,
well I'm probably doing something stupid
that if I quit doing my life would be
better,
that I could quit doing that I would
quit doing.
And maybe it's not a very big thing
because you're not very disciplined,
but maybe there's something to ask
yourself that question,
man,
you'll have an answer and no time flat
like,
well,
I should start doing this.
It's like,
yeah,
I know I could.
I didn't,
you know,
I won't,
but.
Or maybe I would,
but if I did,
I know my life would be better.
It's like you can figure that out
immediately and if you do that 100
times,
well you'll be in way better shape.
So if you don't know what to do,
that's good.
You could at least figure out what you
shouldn't do that's just moronically you
know,
pathetic.
And you can be sure you're doing like a
dozen of those things.
At least you know,
procrastinating or you know,
you know everyone.
That's what the conscience tells you and
if you ask,
they'll just tell you why you're stupid
and insufficient.
And so who wants to hear that?
But what,
maybe you could do something about it.
Okay.
So the cricut comes into the village
there and he sees this,
this like little house and there's a
little fire in it.
And so it's Kinda got a welcoming place.
It's a light in the darkness.
This house just like the star.
And so he hops towards it and then he
ends up inside it and you know,
there's a nice fire and you get to see
the inside and the insights.
It's cozy,
you know,
it's welcoming.
And then when you look around,
you see that everything's kind of in its
place.
It's not hyper organized or anything
like that.
It's friendly and welcoming and it's,
there's a lot of wood and there's a nice
fire and then there's toys everywhere
and they're well constructed.
So you know that whoever lives there
likes children.
And so if someone likes children,
well,
if someone doesn't like children,
it's like you should run away from them
very rapidly.
But if they liked children,
well then that's a good sign that you
know Jesus there,
at least human.
It's a start,
you know?
And then these things are all high
quality.
They're made very well.
And then there's,
and he's looking around to see all of
this and there's,
there's toys and there's clocks and
they're all handmade.
And so he sort of infers that maybe
there's a woodcarver,
who,
who lives there and a woodcarver.
Someone who,
who can build things.
And if you build things that work and
that are beautiful,
that's,
that's a kind of truth,
right?
It's like it's built right into the
object.
That's what quality is.
Quality is the,
the,
the building into an object of truth.
The thing works.
It does what it's supposed to.
It has integrity and so you see that
everywhere inherent,
so you're getting a sense of the,
the,
the film makers are setting the stage
and so while,
so they set the stage by showing you the
stage and the cricket tells you what he
sees and he's pretty happy to be there
because.
And this is also someone who's concerned
about time,
right?
Because there was a lot of clocks,
there's a lot of clocks and so time
turns out to be an important sub element
of this story and then he sees the
puppet marionette and so what's a marion
out?
Well,
a Marionette,
and then he'd be sitting on the shelf.
A marionette is something that's quite
animated because it can move.
It doesn't really have a soul,
but it sort of acts like it has a soul.
It in,
in,
in the sense of anima and soul.
It animated and.
But a Marionette is something that is
being manipulated by something else
behind the scenes,
right?
It doesn't have its own volition.
It's dependent on the will have
something behind the scenes and so
there's a strong implication that
whatever this thing is is half formed
and that it's being manipulated by
unseen forces behind unseen forces
behind the facade.
Well,
that's a freudian idea.
That's you.
That's all of you.
You know,
you're polled hither and fro by
unconscious forces and some of those are
biological and some of them are
cultural,
you know,
and you think about people who are swept
up in great ideological movements like
the Communists or the fascist is like
those people are marrying nets.
That's exactly what they are.
They all say the same thing.
They almost the same words.
They all act the same way and some
things behind it.
And the question is what?
Well,
that is the question and that's partly
what this movie tries to figure out.
So you see this Marionette,
he's at half formed,
wouldn't headed puppet and he has a
little bit of potential,
you know,
and the cricket goes up and interacts
with them and sees that he's made out of
pretty good wood.
It makes a little joke about having a
wooden head and you know,
that's kind of obvious what that means.
And you noticed the cricket is dressed
like a tramp and,
and when you first saw him he wasn't,
he was dressed like a 19 twenties
millionaire.
So,
but no,
but here he's a tramp and this is so
interesting.
It's like,
so this bug,
that's a messiah,
that's the introduction to the book.
That's the conscience is also a tramp
with no home.
It's like what does that mean?
And it took me a long time to sort that
out and it's like he's been everywhere.
This tramp,
he's been everywhere and,
and he knows he's,
he's traveled the world and anybody who
doesn't have a place,
he doesn't have a home.
He hasn't made a relationship with
anything real yet.
He's,
he's kind of a potential.
And this is one of the things that's
really interesting about this movie
because if you think about the cricket
as a fragment of the of the hero and say
a,
a reflection of the of the savior,
which is his relationship with jc of
course,
and the person who introduces the book,
then the story gets strange because if
it was merely a representation of the
perfect person,
the archetype of the hero,
then the conscience would know
everything,
right?
And it would just tell the puppet what
to do and that would be the end of it.
But that,
first of all,
that's adult story.
It's like perfect conscience comes
along.
Puppet does everything.
It says being goal perfection,
but that isn't what happens.
There's this weird idea that this thing
that's got all these attributes needs a
home and has to enter into a learning
relationship with the thing that it's
trying to transform.
It's so sophisticated because you know,
I could say you should do what your
conscience tells you.
It's like,
well,
maybe not.
Maybe that's not exactly how it works.
Maybe your conscience isn't omniscient
and omnipotent.
Maybe it's not gone right.
It's a guide,
but it's,
it's,
it's maybe smarter than you sometimes
maybe because it's society in your head
and obviously it's smarter than you
sometimes because it tells you not to do
something and you go do it and then you
get into trouble and you think,
well,
if I would've just listened,
but you don't,
and that's interesting too.
It's something that you don't have to
listen to,
which is seems to be associated with
freewill.
It's weird.
It's like if your conscience knows what
to do,
why aren't you just a deterministic
puppet of your conscience Christ?
That would work a lot better.
You wouldn't have to torture yourself
and you wouldn't make any mistakes.
So why the separation?
Well,
maybe it's because of the conscience is
generic and so it has to be taught.
It has to learn to,
and so what you do is you have a
dialogue with your conscience.
It's something like that and then you
expose yourself to more and more of the
world and you get wiser in your
conscience gets wiser and new.
You mature together and that's what
happens in this story because the
cricket starts out as a tramp that you
know,
is smarter than the puppet but not as
smart as he thinks he is.
That's for sure.
And when he first starts to operate as a
conscience,
he's completely useless.
Added.
He babbles off a lot of cliches about
morality and then he's late the first
day for his job and he's just not very
good at it.
And so there's this weird idea that the
conscience,
which is part of what puts you towards
redemption is something that you
actually have to interact with over the
course of your life in order for it to
develop as you develop.
And so then I would also say that the
cricket represents,
at least in part what you described as
the self,
which is like the potential fully
developed human being that sort of
exists within you as a possibility,
but it has to be.
It has to be manifest in the actual
conditions of your life.
And so the conscience has to learn how
to position itself here and now and it's
got generic advice and that's not good
enough.
And so that's why the cricket is looking
for a home.
And so he needs a home even though he's
all these other things we already said
he was,
he has to find a specific home before he
can become who he could be.
Well,
so then Japan,
oh,
shows up and he's a kindly old guy,
which is pretty much exactly what you'd
expect.
And you know,
he,
he's a careful craftsman and he likes
kittens and you know,
that's always a good thing.
And he has some fish and I know he's.
And He's good at making things and he's
got a sense of humor and he's kind of
playful.
And so he's,
he's a,
he's a good father.
Fundamentally.
He's the wise king.
He's the positive archetype of the
masculine.
That's what he is.
And so he's culture and its positive
manifestation.
And he gives rise to this creation,
which is his puppet,
which is what culture does because
you're a puppet of your culture,
you're a Marionette of your culture.
And so maybe you could be more than
that,
and that's the other thing that's
strange about this movie,
and it's strange about the mythological
way of looking at the world because
scientifically deterministically,
there's nature and there's culture and
you are the deterministic product of the
interaction between nature and culture.
There's nothing else to you than that.
That's that.
But the mythological world doesn't say
that.
It says something different.
It says that there's nature and culture,
and then there's you and the you that's
in there has choices and the destiny and
that you actually affect the interplay
of nature and culture in determining
your own character.
And it insists upon that.
The oldest stories we have,
there's always the hero and the
archetypal mother and the archetype.
Father.
There's always those three things.
There's never just two.
So from a narrative perspective,
there's always the implication that
there is something autonomous about the,
the hero of the story.